Newsweek writes George Soros prays for
Ron DeSantis rattles Trump supporters
and that's putting it lightly I saw
Gateway pundit wrote George the kiss of
death George Soros endorses Rhonda
Santos which he did not do let me show
you the quick they actually do have the
quote in here quote DeSantis is shrewd
ruthless and ambitious he is likely to
be the Republican candidate this could
induce Trump whose narcissism has turned
into a disease to run as a third party
candidate that would lead to a
democratic Landslide and force the
Republican party to reform itself he
actually said My Hope for 2024 is that
Trump and Governor desensitive Florida
will Slug It Out for the Republican
nomination and then because it would
lead to the Democrats winning so why I I
think I mean I know why I think people
who like Trump are trying to sabotage
Ron DeSantis but
I don't know your thoughts I guess I'm
just I'm kind of pissed off at being
lied to to be honest I'm so glad you
looked up the full quote and can expose
that it is just a complete 100 lie
um coming from Trump supporters yeah
well and the mainstream media don't get
me wrong you know right but at least
Newsweek puts it lightly they're like he
prays to Santa's praised him no he
called him ruthless
I just thought it was stupid they've
convinced me that this is a dog
um and that's why I'm very happy to see
fake news from Anne I just think it's
stupid to decide whether you like a
politician or a person based on who else
likes that person or doesn't like that
person that's what you do when you have
you're looking at a black box you have
no other information who is this Ron
DeSantis you speak of we know about
Rhonda I don't care I I don't care who
endorses him I know the things he's done
he opened up the state Trump shut it
down
um he's read the Great Barrington
declaration guys Trump listened to fauci
and allowed him to run covid policy uh
he sent the illegals to to Martha's
Vineyard the greatest political stunt of
my lifetime yeah wow funny and people
wow he's so mad about that yes I mean it
was after all the busing and everything
to take to take the extra step to go to
Martha's Vineyard and man was that a hit
he hired more police offered police
being harassed other places to come and
get a five thousand dollar bonus to come
work in Florida I mean he's he's just
been done hit after hit after hit so I
don't care who endorses him
they told us he was going to die in a
week and here he is he's looking like
he's getting a little thick he's
starting to eat again he gained um a
quarter pound in the first week after
stem cell treatment he just got another
injection yesterday and some
subcutaneous fluids today so he looks
like a little muscular what does he have
it's um kidney failure they call it it's
third is he a drinker what's that yeah
he's been no he's a street cat he's
never developed correctly yeah he has
got underdeveloped kidneys and a bad
heart so but he started since the stem
cell treatment and the change in his
diet he's extremely a lot better he's
like John Federman yeah stem cells we
got him this experimental stem cell
treatment is it depressed no not anymore
he's doing better he had to shave his
little legs
fourth one though he's got I know my
legs and one that's still fluffy so
anyway we were talking about uh Rhonda
santis and Donald Trump uh so what do
you thinking you're voting uh DeSantis
2024 if he runs right now though I I'm
if if the cameras weren't running I'd
say of course I am he's the best
candidate out there he's the best in my
lifetime
um but since the cameras are running I
want Ron DeSantis to have to fight for
my vote so yes I'm considering him very
strongly we'll see
what uh I mean you've been on you've
been on Twitter quite vocal about Donald
Trump
yes yes both ways I mean I did write in
Trump We Trust
um and I was introducing the rallies two
weeks after he announced out in Iowa and
elsewhere and look if you read in Trump
We Trust I wouldn't take back a single
word of it in fact I have given it to
certain Republican presidential
candidates I want to read it saying but
you actually have to do it
um because the what the 2016 campaign I
think was the greatest presidential
campaign in world history but in the
book I make it very clear he's an awful
person he's a con man he's a grifter
um horrible tacky vulgarian got all that
but he's the only one offering us this
basket of issues I want to vote on
obviously number one immigration number
two three and four immigration and the
wall bringing trade back this worship of
free trade
um and no more stupid Wars those were
like the three biggest things and then
any supported things like you know gun
rights very strongly
um and then you know he gets into office
and starts talking about amnestying the
dreamers they're the ones I wanted to
Port first because their boss again
obnoxious at least you know you catch
another illegal alien and they say okay
you got me no dreamers how dare you not
give me amnesty so Trump gets elected
not doesn't build the wall builds 33
miles you know six months before the
election it's a 2000 mile border he
takes Kim Kardashian noted criminologist
um to to push through laws releasing
criminals that which you know that's a
huge hit with Americans especially after
2020. that's great yeah you always know
how to be a celebrity right like that
that reminded me of the reality TV show
aspect of trump right he knew he knew I
don't I think you're giving him more I
don't even think it's knowing how to be
I think he is a narcissistic I I didn't
the one thing I didn't know when I wrote
in Trump We Trust is how profoundly
stupid he is
um I made very clear in the book The
only thing he could do we will forgive
him for anything and I defended him the
day after the Access Hollywood you know
grabbing tape came out I was
giving a speech before like 5 000 people
in California up in farmland and I was
peddled to the metal defending him
and and you know I said well forgive
them for anything but unless you betray
us on immigration oh and guess what he
did you can't do every campaign rally
build the wall build the wall build the
wall and then not build the wall and
expect to get reelected well that was
the best part of your Twitter account
for me for a long time with you your how
many days like no progress on the wall
border wall updates yeah and you I mean
you were intense about it you were one
of the most vocal people keeping his
feet to the fire on the border wall yeah
that works look you fought a good fight
here I mean you can't say that you did
it try I will say to be fair the the
areas that got secure did reduce
illegal immigration in key points you
didn't get a beautiful five million
illegals have come in since Biden's been
president well there's a reason we
wanted a wall a wall is forever and
these people these my my my allies on
the immigration issue who say
um oh the wall that's it's a metaphor we
don't just enforce Eve arifi okay
e-verify goes away with the next
president Refugee limits go away with
the next president a wall is forever
Americans were correct to vote for the
guy no matter how much of a Despicable
moronic grifting human being he was he
promised us a wall and that's why people
voted is DeSantis going to get us a wall
um what I like I think so I think so I
think so I absolutely do and the reason
I say it with that enthusiasm is what I
like about
DeSantis is Trump was all talk no action
DeSantis is no talk
yeah
what did you think of Doug ducey's um
shipping container wall he like put the
shipping containers in the gaps and took
it down yeah they were super mad about
it
what did you think I mean do you like
that that's why we want a wall and not a
Cheesy little fence that's true I used
to think the wall was such a silly idea
because I was like they'll just go
around it or under it or they'll send
drones over it I didn't realize until
the last couple years how much how much
human trafficking is just happening on a
daily basis that I've got this armband
from yeah this is it says
which means delivered this is put around
the hand the arms of young children that
are sent across the border as cat as as
Commodities basically to be sold no the
people that are being trafficked get
marked by this and then we also have
yeah we have that ID a fake ID that they
use to try and get make fake Asylum
claims it's crazy that and we are a
magnet for that sort of human
trafficking it's sick it's sick it's
sick that we're doing this it's sick
that we're doing it to them and it's
just people who hate America and they're
they're willing to risk these human
lives to wreck our contract I think it's
uh completely in line with what
Democrats do short-term gains for
long-term losses one of the big
strategies Democrats have is to
artificially prop up the failing economy
with this economic maximizing as much
demand as possible through illegal
immigration ignoring all the negative
consequences and then 10 years down the
line we're gonna we're gonna face this
very serious economic crisis from it but
they're hoping that they can boost
numbers in the short term to make it
look good
and what are they that's true too but
long term they win also they look at
California
yeah the entire country will be
California highest taxes in the country
least least numbers of services people
who work for a living are just oppressed
harassed they have to walk through you
know human feces to get to work homeless
camps all over that is your future
America do you think that the allowance
of the this happening across the border
is one of three reasons maybe because
they can't stop it so it's like what are
we gonna do two because they want
uh a huge population that they can turn
into military men I don't know maybe
that's part of it that they want more
fodder for the war machine so they're
letting them in and they're like hey you
can earn your citizens I think they're
not against that but not I think that's
not the number it's more just like
they're overwhelmed and they're like we
don't know how to stop it so we're not
no no that is absolute never believe
that I mean they act that way so sorry I
shouldn't be that dismissive yeah they
all act oh what are you gonna do and oh
people can climb over a wall yeah tell
it to Israel
tell it to China to the capital complex
that put up the wall just the other day
walls always work I mean it's like
saying don't put a lock on your door
isn't that a nice car on a new bed and
focus is laying on stem cells on that I
could use it
um you don't lock your door because you
know a burglar could I don't know take a
hatchet to it or something I mean Israel
had the wall goes deep deep down when
Israel put up its wall
um it cut down uh illegal immigration by
more than 90 percent that wasn't good
enough for Israel so they found after
they had built the wall which parts of
the wall were the most vulnerable and
built those extra high no walls walls
work drones don't work boots on the
ground don't work Thai Tech doesn't work
what are we gonna do watch them run
across that's all an excuse for no wall
open border the only thing that works is
a wall and as for why they wanted it
well long-term Democrats are sitting
pretty in California you came from
California they control every branch of
government
um the illegals who are coming in I I
will say they are very hard workers
they're very nice I bear them no ill
will
um and they really are hard workers um
but they also consume a lot of
government benefits and they vote
overwhelmingly Democrat and that's what
happened to California
Hispanics are now a plurality it
certainly was completely the opposite it
was like one of the whitest states in
the union California it was it was the
Beach Boys now there are plurality and
Democrats control the state and that's
what will happen to the entire country
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time